welcome back to pj gen design today we
are going to talk about how to create
this four prong setting with the
cathedral ring shank are you ready let's
get started
[Music]
we're going to starting with the round
stone here and you can download this
stone at the description below uh just
sign up the newsletter then you will get
a link to download the storm to follow
along so let's starting with the front
view every time when i starting to
making a ring always front view because
we need to know the ring size and many
people has asked me like what size
should i do should i do it bigger
smaller because the shrinkage i always
will suggest you do exactly the same
size of the ring
so now we have the ring size here for my
demo is 16 millimeter in the diameter
and we need to start drawing the shape
before we
set it up for the ring i'd like to do
the setting first so let's go ahead to
draw the settings i'm going to draw a
straight line for the jeweler to set
which means you will need to have the
prong is a bit uh longer and i'm going
to draw something like this a little bit
over the center so that will be
overlapping there and i want to draw
something look like this and if it is
not the right one it's okay we can
always change later a few things you
need to consider first is this prong too
thin compared to this stone the prong
itself right now if i
measure this is like 0.8 millimeter and
that's the stone itself if you measure
with the vertex and we are going to get
from
this point to
this point and that's
5.63 millimeter that might be okay but i
also want to make sure that it's enough
also you can have a stone cutting 20
percent the most right so i would like
to pick up those two points kind of move
it down just a little bit like this all
right and i always like to have this pro
just a little bit taller than the table
and if you are going to go for the
rendering purpose i will suggest you go
something like this
and instead of have the flat surface we
are going to delete this one and we can
simply just blend in between in between
here and here okay and if this is too
puffy you can always holding the shift
move it down so they will move it down
two arm at the same time and let's click
okay
now let's join all of this back
and since i already do that i'm going to
attend this is for the rendering and i'm
just gonna join them all right we are
going to
having a shank like a bridge underneath
it so this may not need to go all the
way to the bottom so we might need to
move this up right but you don't want to
touch the stone bottom too much we might
just simply moving this one up a little
bit
okay
it will be nice everywhere has a little
bit fitted so i'm going to use the
fillet and let's try
0.35
and i'm going to
fill it the corner here inside is
actually doesn't matter
because this will be blocking from the
stone at the rendering but i still like
to fit it that as well and i want to
fill it this part as well okay
this part right here in the middle will
be overlapping so that'll be fine let's
take a look on the top view so we got
something like this the stone doesn't
cut more than 20 percent of the prong
prong is thick enough
and to making this strong we can simply
just
using the solid extruded planar curve
straight and giving a thickness that's
one way to do
now in some cases you might want to make
it a little bit tapered from the top so
what you can do is coming over here i'm
going to moving this one to the side a
little bit and just tilt it with the
gumball just a little bit like this
and we wanted to mirror that piece
to the other side so now i have two
curves there i can use the commands
called loft
i'm gonna loft in between this
all right so this is what you see
you can see this taper is more graceful
and if you like the shape and how it
taper you can use the command cap cap
and you will close it so now it will
become solid
once again take a look on the render
view and see if that is the proper size
now is everything look alright to you
this is too sharp for the rendering
purpose so i'm going to do the fillet
edges now remember last time we fit it
right at this point it was
0.35 so what i like to do is do
something smaller otherwise i will have
issue let's do 0.2
and we want to chain edges equal yes on
the top
command bar and we're going to click on
everything here we don't actually need
to
fit it on the very
center straight line so that's fine and
as hit enter
and we'll get something like this double
check if that is round enough if you end
up with naked edges if not
we're gonna do it again
and hit enter
okay
so that is one prong we will need to
have four prong i simply just wanna use
array puller and we're gonna snapping
into the zero number is equal four
and uh we want 360 degrees or we'll get
something like this
all right so now in order to have our
setting look nice i need to have all
this prong right here
to be rotated 45 degrees so they are in
this orientation there okay
that's hiding this curve over here
and let's take a look on the rest of the
shank now the shrink what i like to do
is have something really nicely flow
into here right so let's go ahead to
split with the point
on this one and this one so they become
top and the bottom
the one on the top i'm going to draw a
straight line and remember now you are
snapping everywhere you can disable your
old snap so you're not snapping crazy
and i'm going to draw a straight line
going up like this okay what it does
it's going to help us to draw a really
nice curve by using the command called
blend and i'm going to blend
from this end of the straight line that
we just draw
and to the bottom curve right there
so i'm going to turning into the
wireframe and going to use the blank
command and i'm going to blend between
this straight line
to the bottom line right there as you
can see this line currently is cutting
into
the circle which is inside of our ring
shank and that is not going to work so
i'm going to moving this bar up and
going to move this one up as well
so then click ok and that will be the
curve we wanted to use for the sweep
that's working on the profile i'm going
to draw
a rectangle
again snapping into the end point all
the quadrant depends on how thick you
want on this ring so it's roughly over
two millimeter over one millimeter thick
and i'm also going to
explode it and we don't need this one
that's using the arc tool snapping into
the endpoint to the endpoint coming up
like this
and don't forget to join all of them
and kind of moving from the midpoint to
the quadrant
if you feel like this is a little bit
too thick you can always turn on the
control point and kind of just moving
the point to change the thickness
again i like everything it's nice and
round so i'm going to give it the fillet
let's fill it the corner let's try point
three and it will get something like
this
all right let's give it a try if i'm
going to use sweep one rail and this is
your rail this is your cross section and
you will get something like this and
notice that it keeps exactly the same
thickness and it's kind of folding there
too is because we have this coming up
like that and it doesn't look nice so
what i like to do is i'm going to making
a copy with the gumball just hit the all
key and we'll get something like this
and i also want to rotate this guy a
little bit and to make them taper let's
go ahead to 3d scale and moving
this profile
back to here talking underneath it
something like that
all right let's give it a try we are
going to use the sweep one rail let's go
ahead sweep one and this time make sure
you record the history this is the rail
this is your cross section
and this is the second cross section and
that's hit enter and we'll get something
like this
all right it looks nice to me also check
on the side and see if that is the good
thickness over there
all right so let's give it the test we
are going to pick up the curve and also
this piece let's mirror to the other
side
and we want to create a bottom of a ring
shank by going sweep one rail again and
we're gonna
using this cross section and this cross
section there
and hit enter and it will get something
like this
before you join them i would like to
create this bridge one more time now if
i am going to use this as a rail let's
go to the surface i want to sweep one
rail and gonna go from here this is your
cross section this is your cross section
you also want to record a history hit
enter and we'll get something like this
all right so basically i have this
exactly the same thickness like a button
that we have and it's quite thick over
there
so what we can do is simply just one d
scale
down to the proper thickness
and to see how it goes now
right here on the top it seems a little
bit too tall too
so instead of using this curve i'm
actually need to making a copy by
control c and control v and 3d scale
down this guy so not only i'm making it
not as wide also thinner too and we're
gonna moving this guy
to the quadrant let's give it a try i'm
going to use the
sweep one rail
this is the rail this is the cross
section
and now we'll get something like this
let's go ahead to record the history one
more time and double make sure that's
what you want now if this is kind of a
two thing to you because i do not like
this point coming out i do want to have
the top is a little bit wider since we
recorded history we can just want these
scale with the gumball and they were
coming out a little bit like this
all right so if that looked nice to you
let's go ahead to join this guy this guy
and this guy with the join command
and to close it
we can use the cap command cap again
and we pick up this one to close it now
this is a solid but it's really a
straight cut over there so we're gonna
use the fitted edges
and let's try point two with the chain
age and see how it goes
all right as you can see like this has
some issue over there as you can see
this is overlapping and this is extra
space coming out so let's did it this
one i guess we need to try smaller than
the 0.2 so let's try 0.1 there again
chain h
and then that will work double make sure
right here on the closed solid poly
surface that is still applied
and we're gonna coming over here for
this
okay so now we pretty much finished this
one but one thing i would like to
address is the production
so now think about this even without a
stone
you print and cast the whole piece
the most difficult place to polish will
be this area right there with the point
and also all the area in between this
prong this will be really hard to polish
right so a lot of time what i will do is
i will separate them into two parts so
we need to make a puzzle piece first is
this red one
and then the other one is this one and
so to make sure the puzzle nicely this
is what i will do
i will actually making a copy ctrl c and
control v and hiding one of it with this
one i'm going to pull in difference with
this one
so you can see on the bottom this is
really nice curve that i will fit into
that bridge over there
and then i'm gonna come into the top to
make a cylinder
starting from the midpoint
and this pulse doesn't have to be too
big so i want to do the diameter it's
about
0.8 millimeter
so let's type it 0.8
and then as long as it's longer than the
bridge that will be fine then we're
going to go back with this bridge and
what we wanted to do again now is making
a copy
of this post
and one of it i'm going to turn it into
the red color
and this one it's going to boiling unit
with the head there
the other one right there
just want to enlarge tiny bit
and i would like to boil in difference
this guy out of this guy
all right so now if i
moving this piece up
and what you're going to see is a hole
over there so what we're going to do is
cast them separately
and once you get polished you can have
this one
soldering back and simply just flow some
solder here and trim the extra so the
whole piece will be nice and polished i
hope you enjoyed the video please let me
know how you like it leave the comment
below thank you for watching and i'll
see you next
[Music]
you